today on the Matt Walsh show many of us
are worried that our current lockdown
strategy is leading us quickly into an
economic collapse unlike anything this
country has ever seen before but the
left-wing media says that if you're
worried about the economy at a time like
this then you are a heartless Scrooge
putting money above people which of
course is nonsense we're going to talk
about that today also five headlines
including for a change of pace you know
we're used to seeing the the the
confrontations in the grocery store over
toilet paper well we have one over
Mountain Dew so I figure that's a nice
change of pace I'll play that video for
you and a listener writes to explain why
I'm wrong in advocating that we open up
the economy to avoid the depression all
of that on the way but let's start with
this and I have to tell you I am I'm
pretty mad pretty ticked off which I
which I know speaking of change of pace
that's that's quite a change of pace for
me but listen up I I think a person can
take any number of positions on this
crisis and and what the path what the
best path forward is and any idea of any
path we choose has the potential to
result in suffering and death in fact
that's gonna be part of the package no
matter what we do that's the situation
that we're in that's that's the reality
of it we have to face that we can't we
can't hide from it so I'm not gonna get
angry at anyone who has really grappled
with this and come to a conclusion
however tentative it might be even if
that conclusion is different from mine
because we can all as honest and
compassionate people there are there are
many different ways of looking at this
thing but what I'm seeing especially
from people in the media is a is a bad
faith dishonest disgusting effort to
shut down shout down those of us who
suggest that perhaps it's not a good
idea to deliberately crash the economy
to deliberately cause a Great Depression
in order to stop a virus what I'm seeing
from from these people again many in the
media is an attempt to make a caricature
of our position which is a reasonable
position in a serious position but they
have painted it as putting money over
people or even as eugenics I've seen
that quite a bit which is pretty rich
coming from the pro-abortion fanatics
that they are what they want to do is
portray us as greedy uncaring unfeeling
Scrooge's who would rather have millions
die than see our portfolios damaged now
this is as I said nonsense it's worse
than nonsense actually and it makes me
strongly suspect that those employing
this strategy in the media actually want
the economy to collapse that's actually
what they want to see happen and I don't
say that lightly but but I can't figure
out figure out why else they would be
doing this why else they would be so
flippant about the the potential
collapse of our economy why else they
would pretend that to worry about the
collapse of the economy is is somehow to
worry only about money as if there's as
if as if you could actually separate the
economy from the people who comprise it
now we'll circle back to this in a
second but first let's just review again
where we are because I think it's very
important we're now being warned as I
reported yesterday that 30% unemployment
is on the horizon very very close on the
horizon the collapse of the commercial
mortgage market could be close behind
after that and these are just the
relatively immediate consequences of
closing thousands of businesses for an
indefinite period of time keep in mind
that the worst employment rate as I said
yesterday the worst employment rate ever
in American history was 25 percent
during the Great Depression the worst my
generation has ever seen
10% and we had that about 10 years ago I
think back in 2009 this would be then
three times worse than anyone in my
generation has ever seen and if you
remember the 10% unemployment people
were freaking out over that this is
three times worse than that
to emphasize this point this process is
already underway 140,000 unemployment
claims were filed in Ohio just in Ohio
just last week in the first week of the
shutdown
in 40,000 unemployment claims so many
unemployment claims were filed that it
shut down and crashed the website the
unemployment website in Ohio in Arizona
there were their unemployment website
also crashed when they received 30,000
people filing in a single week in New
York last Thursday in one day they
received over half a million visits to
the unemployment site also crashed the
site the next day they got a half a
million calls inquiring about
unemployment so you've got unemployment
web sites across the country crashing
from from the from the the amount of
traffic they're getting from people who
are suddenly out of a job
millions and millions of people out of
work no income no way to provide for
themselves after one week one week okay
it wasn't even a full week for a lot of
people just a few days of a company
being shut down and already they're
laying people off and they're firing
people and not because they're greedy
not because these companies are run by
Reedy by greedy fat cats who don't care
about the the little man know most most
companies in America are small
businesses and the reason why they're
getting rid of people firing laying off
they have no choice they can't operate
with zero revenue they have to they have
no choice now the hope I suppose is that
the jobs will be there to return to once
the government lets people go back to
work and this is what I've heard this is
the argument I've heard I've heard
things like well the economy can be
resurrected in fact that's what somebody
in some media person some journalist
said to me on Twitter yesterday you can
resurrect the economy just resurrect it
like Jesus on Easter morning just
residue of miracle resurrected look at
that know that that hope is as CNN might
say unsubstantiated most small
businesses cannot survive on zero
revenue for very long let alone months
when they go down they're done they're
not going to be resurrected they don't
magically come back to life it's not
happened that's not what happens with a
business even the significantly larger
companies are going to have to downsize
and
when when the government says ok you can
go back to work it's not it's it's not
like the past however many weeks and
months disappear like they never
happened and what will happen in the
meantime to people a large majority of
Americans are already living paycheck to
paycheck a large majority now paycheck
to paycheck means if you miss one
paycheck you're in trouble especially if
you have kids what happens when you miss
two paychecks three four five what
happens to you how do you feed yourself
how do you feed your kids how will you
pay the rent with a mortgage government
stimulus checks only goes so far yes
send the checks and we'll talk about
those checks during the headlines but
that can't be a new way of life we can't
sustain the entire country that way no
matter what the Socialists might say
people need to work to care for
themselves and their families what
happens when millions of people are
prevented from doing so for a long
stretch of time well nobody knows the
answer to that question really because
nothing like this has ever happened
before no government as far as I'm aware
has ever ever ever willfully plunged
itself into a depression obliterating
obliterating its own economy on purpose
in order to prevent some other potential
calamity if we go that route we will be
the first to ever try it along with the
other countries that are some other
countries in the world right now that
are currently trying it - that's a whole
other aspect of this thing that we're
not even talking about we're just
talking about America crashing its
economy what happens when a bunch of
other economies crash also at the same
time across the globe well we don't know
exactly but I think there's there are
many very good reasons to predict rather
horrifying results from such an
experiment destitution poverty on a
massive scale looting rioting millions
homeless that's just the beginning you
know we have seen looting and rioting in
major American cities in recent history
for almost no reason in Baltimore they
said it was about Freddie gray
I think the guy that was allegedly a
victim of police brutality
well of course most the looters didn't
really care about Freddie gray or even
know about that situation or know much
about it they were just looking for an
excuse what happens when you give them a
legitimate excuse what happens when you
make people desperate what happens when
you make even decent people who could
never have even imagined themselves
looting what happens when you make them
consider it because they need a loaf of
bread for their kids and they can't they
have no way of buying it
now this 15-day period is one thing but
if it goes exponentially longer than
that it's just it's just that that is an
option that cannot be on the table we
cannot open our arms and embrace exactly
the kind of catastrophe that the
shutdown's are supposed to be preventing
many lives will be ruined lives human
lives now I'm not sure that it will be
entirely safe to go back to work after
15 days I think the 15-day period
probably I suspect was sort of arbitrary
but we have no other choice if we want
to preserve our civilization does that
mean that we fling open our doors and
run outside and start infecting each
other with abandon no of course not
here's the plan that I outlined
yesterday I'm gonna I'll say it again
and I expand it a little bit tell me
where I'm wrong here let's go over this
one more time
step one open the economy let young and
healthy people feed their families step
to encourage masks produce produce lots
of masks get them out there and
encourage them maybe even require them
for certain industries in certain
situations where transmission might be
especially likely likely in areas where
there might be a large gatherings of
people in a confined space maybe you say
for a time they're hot you have to wear
masks okay
step 3 keeping homes quarantined step 4
tell other at-risk people to remain in
their homes from now step 5 test
aggressively quarantine the infected
step 6 provide financial relief to
at-risk people who cannot work we do all
of those things now I'm not saying
that's going to solve
problem I don't think this is a problem
that can be solved so much is managed at
this point but why wouldn't that manage
the problem okay that's not doing
nothing I'm not saying that we do
nothing I certainly don't think we
should do nothing I'm not I'm not
someone saying that this is no big deal
we shouldn't even have to worry about it
it's nothing but the flu yada yada
that's not my position I think it is
serious but crashing the economy and
destroying millions of lives just cannot
be a solution it is a form of collective
suicide it's killing the patient to stop
the disease you can't do that it can't
be a solution so what's another solution
what about this this is not choosing the
economy or people the economy is people
so if you hear that the economy is
destroyed that means millions of
people's lives are destroyed that's what
it means on the ground the economy is
not some kind of separate entity that
hovers above us detached uninvolved just
up there you say I look at the economy
hi economy
now the economy's not doing so well
today well that's all right we all
comprise the economy we're part of the
economy so when I said I want the
economy to crash I mean that I don't
want people's lives to crash
now I've already said I would love it if
in a long term and by that I mean
generations like probably many
generations but in the long term I think
we should work towards a society in an
economy that could actually withstand
something like this where people could
go a few weeks or several weeks or even
a few months without buying a lot of
stuff and we could survive it I think
that that's we should be working towards
an economy like that over the long term
an economy that is not so consumer based
an economy where people are more
self-sufficient where there's a where
it's it's more focused on the home life
and supporting the nuclear family than
it is on supporting retail shops
everything else but that's that's the
long-term that's we can't do that
overnight which is what we're trying to
do now you do it overnight and you're
going
to have massive massive suffering and
death but what we're hearing from the
media especially left-wing media is that
anybody who expresses these concerns
hates people hates the elderly is cruel
is heartless this is the rhetoric all
over MSNBC all over CNN but let me give
you a just a little taste of things that
some people in the media and and other
blue checks on Twitter journalists and
so on have been saying to me as I've
been making these arguments since on
social media these are the kinds of
responses I've been getting from from
these people just just a few examples
says Matt can work from home but all you
expendable peasants get back to the
front line so the stock market doesn't
crash anymore
f me our society is terrible another one
another capitalist well I can't even
read that the implication is I'm a
capitalist and I have a fetish for mass
murder that's what it's it's this is
this is mass murder that I'm advocating
another one we're gonna hear this line
ball take a lot soon but there's too
much money at stake to not let people
get infected and die someone else so
throw the bodies of service and
industrial workers at the virus while
people like Matt Walsh continue to work
from home because they can
sorry expendable young people but
capitalism would like to carry on so
shut the F up and go back to work I care
about people not dying you're a fool so
on and so on you get the idea if you if
you say that we don't want to we have to
take steps to make sure there's not a
depression you don't you you don't care
about people dying you in fact are in
favor of mass murder
you're throwing young people and the
elderly off a cliff essentially
sacrificing them for your own bottom
line your 401k your portfolio your stock
options and everything else now III am
saying not just me lots of people are
saying if the economy crashes if we
become the first country ever in history
that chooses to crash its own economy
the result will be catastrophic
traffic for people for working families
for parents who won't be able to feed
and clothe their children not just for
the stock market
not for portfolios for people actual
people not just 401ks
although by the way you know 401ks are
pretty important if all of our 401ks
plummet that's that's that's gonna cause
a lot of suffering to people not rich
people people who are relying on that so
that's that's not a small thing this is
what I'm talking about people are
dismissive uh just just a 401k what are
you talking about that somebody's
savings they're relying on that to live
on these are people and and whether you
agree or not with the plan to end the
shutdowns I don't believe that any
rational person any sane person could
actually interpret this argument as an
argument for letting people die just for
the sake of money
I don't believe that any person who
claims to hear it that way really does
because you would have to be a lunatic
to interpret it that way I think they're
pretending I think these people in media
that are saying oh it's money over
people I think they're pretending to see
it that way why well keep in mind every
person ever everyone who left one of
those comments I just read all of them
and the pundits on on cable news they
were they're fine they still have jobs
either they work from home or they can
still go to their TV studio and do their
job they have an income stream it's not
shut off like mine is not shut off
they're doing okay like me we'll be okay
media is a booming business right now
now sure eventually if there's a great
depression
it will probably destroy my life too so
it's not like I have no skin in this
game you know media depends on
advertiser advertisers and if you can't
afford to advertise if a bunch of
companies all go down can't advertise
anymore then then that then we're
finished also now we have subscribers
also but if subscribers have to choose
between paying their subscriptions
and paying for the rent we know which
one they're gonna choose and should
choose so I'm not immune if this whole
ship goes down I'm in the water with
everybody else or nearly everybody else
but for now I'm okay and so are all
these people pretending to care so much
about people and yet completely ignoring
the people the millions of people whose
lives are being ruined right now as we
speak not just ruined people will die if
the economy collapses people won't be
able to afford to live and there will be
suicide a lot of it
studies show not surprisingly that
suicide rates increase along with
recessions as the economy recedes
suicide rates increase what will happen
during a historic crash unlike anything
we've ever seen before
40,000 people according to an article I
was just reading in the Atlantic 40,000
people killed themselves in America in
the years 1937 and 1938 a few years
after the depression and you would
expect actually to see the suicide rate
maybe lagging behind a little bit
because people are hanging on for a
while and then their whole lives go to
hell and that's when you really see the
suicide rate kick up so the rate per
100,000 citizens back in 1937 and 1938
how that works out on that basis is the
highest ever recorded suicide
homelessness civil unrest looting that's
what we're looking at and all of that
equates to
human beings suffering and dying the
point here is so obvious I don't mean
that it's obvious that you should agree
with me but just that the economic
collapse obviously means suffering and
death and therefore people who are
saying we need to do everything we can
to avoid that are trying to avoid
suffering and death that is so obvious
that those who are mischaracterizing
this has money over people well as I
said I have no choice but to assume they
have some other motive and I can't
figure out what their motive would be
either they're lunatics and they really
just don't understand the really simple
concepts that are being put before
before them you know they're lunatics or
they have the IQ know they have you know
room temperature IQs and so they hear
about another Great Depression and they
think oh that's nothing we'll be fine
well be fine you could shake that one
off and keep going rub some dirt on it
we'll be all right so either it's that
they're extremely extremely stupid or
crazy or there's something else going on
here
and you begin to suspect that some of
these people actually want the economy
to collapse not just because of how
we'll hurt Trump that's that's certainly
part of it but even Brett you've heard
some of those comments I read about
capitalism there's a disturbing amount
of that of well you see this is what
capitalism does this is capitalism's
problem I think there are some far left
radicals who are thinking okay let's
crash the economy let's destroy
capitalism and then we can rebuild it
rebuild it into our socialist utopia I
think there's some of that going on too
let's move on to headlines 5 headlines
number one Nancy Pelosi last night
introduced her own stimulus package and
people on the right are very upset
because she put a lot of left-wing pork
into the bill tried to use this crisis
as a as an opportunity to ram her
ideological agenda through and people
are upset yeah it's bad honestly though
it's so utterly expected and predictable
that I can't even muster the energy to
be upset about it I assume that's what
they're gonna do it's like getting upset
at a fly for buzzing around you're
garbage
it's what a fly does how can you even
yeah it's annoying but to get angry it's
it's hard to even get angry about it
here's the part that for me is is most
upsetting forget about the pork her
actual ideas for the stimulus itself
that's the bad part so here's what she
wants to do quick rundown $1500 checks
for individuals of $3,000 for joint
filers $1500 per kid up to three kids
max of seventy $7,500 per family every
taxpayer gets a check okay so far so
good
that part I think is actually better
than what the Republicans came up with
here's here's where we go off the rails
individuals making 75 K in 2020 will pay
some or all of it back now wait a second
pay it back first of all pay it back at
75,000 75,000 is not wealthy especially
depending on where you live like we
talked about with the Republican package
this is one of the problems with trying
to do this kind of means-testing thing
it really depends on where you live
seventy-five thousand dollars around New
York is not wealthy okay you're not
living a luxurious life and if you have
kids you have a family forget about it
so first of all you set the limit at
seventy-five thousand but even the idea
you got to pay it back so this is not
stimulus this is not a relief this is
debt you're giving debt to American
families so total American family you're
giving them seven thousand dollars of
debt saying here's here it is
we're gonna need that back from you and
that becomes even more absurd when you
consider this is our own money we're
getting back that's the way we should
think of this it's the government
preventing people from working we're the
ones who fund the government and so the
government is saying or should be saying
this is the way it is it should be
framed this is the reality we're gonna
give you some of your own money back but
now what they're saying is we're gonna
loan you back your own money that you
gave us but you're gonna have to repay
your own money back to us that we gave
you so you have to repay the repayment I
find that ridiculous
number two well you've heard about
people panic buying toilet paper
what about panic buying Mountain Dew I
don't know if this video will spark a
run on the soda aisle we'll see but
video has surfaced of a man in Kentucky
yelling at cashiers at a Kroger because
they won't let him by 500 and well over
500 cans like it's 552 cans of Mountain
Dew that he wants to buy they won't let
him buy it apparently when the video
picks up he'd already bought a whole
bunch of boxes of Mountain Dew put him
in his car and come back for another
round and that's when he was told
okay we're cutting you off and now
before I play this clip so we've got a
guy I tried to buy 552 cans of Mountain
Dew I want you to imagine in your head
what you think this guy will look like
this is always a fun game a guy who
tries to buy 552 cans of Mountain Dew
during a pandemic that's what he's
hoarding his Mountain Dew imagine that
just put put his image all in your mind
sketch sketch sketch the know do the
little kind of police sketch in your in
your mind of what this person looks like
hold that image in your head and here's
the clip
[Music]
you nailed it didn't you you had that
guy pegged especially the hairstyle that
is the hairstyle of a mountain Dew
drinker and I no disrespect
okay this is not any because listen if
you heard about a guy breaking down in
tears at the liquor store because he
wasn't allowed to buy 500 bottles of
Goose Island IPA you would expect him to
look like this this is what you would in
fact you would expect him to be me
that's what you would expect so we all
we all look like what we drink I suppose
and and so that's that's that's what
that is all I can say though is that
this the cashier saved that man's life
because that much Mountain Dew would
kill a whole herd of elephants let alone
a human being and I'm not even kidding
this one can of Mountain Dew has 46
grams of sugar and half the caffeine
content of a can of redbull so you throw
four or five of those back in a day
think about the amount of sugar and
caffeine you've just put into your body
also there's a problem that Mountain Dew
tastes like somebody mixed club soda and
goat urine with half a pound of Splenda
and that's the other problem it's just
it's not my not my favorite thing in the
world number three and the latest
cancellation due to the China virus or a
postponement at any rate is the Olympics
reading from Fox News says the global
spread of the corona virus has forced
the Tokyo Olympics to be postponed until
next summer at the latest japan's Prime
Minister announced he said that he and
the International Olympic Committee
president Thomas Bach came to an
agreement to postpone the games the
latest the event can take place is the
summer of 2021 number four people on
social media are beginning to panic over
another virus in China the hunt
virus there was reports of a man dying
on a bus now I mentioned this here and
it was what I saw on social media was a
number-one trending thing hantavirus so
I mentioned here only to tell you that
if you did hear about it there's no
reason to freak out or worry it is not
spread from person to person says the
CDC it is not a pandemic kind of disease
in that way here's how you get it you
get it from interacting with the the
feces or urine of rats interacting with
so don't do that
and that's a good even without the
hantavirus good general principle if you
see the feces or urine of a rat don't
interact with it I really wouldn't do
anything with respect to it I don't
interact don't have a conversation just
just keep on moving and you have to ask
how did this guy get it well in fairness
you could get it from inhaling so if you
had a rat feces if you had a feet rat
feces all over your floor you were
sweeping it up you could inhale it get
it that way but they do also eat mice
and rats over in that part of the world
so who knows and then that's why China
is sort of becoming a bit of a pandemic
factory number five finally this perhaps
is less of a global news story and more
more of a perhaps more sort of a
regional news story but I do have to
report because I know you want to hear
that the score is now two to zero
against my wife in our quarantine board
game dual reports suggests that we
played Scrabble two nights ago
a game in which I surged back and a
heroic come-from-behind victory thanks
in part to playing the word cheat on a
triple word score the word Jeet is a
legitimate Scrabble or GI te and as you
know it is a small furnished home in
France that's what everybody knows
that's what that means and I put that on
a triple word that's kind of how I
sealed the deal at the end of the day
and you I had to really dig deep into
the scrabble dictionary like that and I
did win the game and then last night we
played Stratego a game which I dominated
from the very first from from the
whistle assassinating my wife's general
killing her spy decimating all of her
high-ranking officers before
matically capturing her flag in in a
shell of strategic brilliance that I
think will be studied by military
schools for centuries to come now I know
a lot of people are playing board games
during quarantine and just be glad that
you are not quarantined with me because
I am widely regarded as the greatest
board game champion certainly in the
country and when I say widely regarded
that way I mean that I regard myself
that way and I tell people this all the
time and when they hear me say that the
first thing they probably think is what
a sad life this pitiful man must lead
and that's probably true but in any case
that's the headline the news you were
waiting to hear now let's go on to our
daily cancellation today we're canceling
all of the media outlets that tried to
blame President Trump for the fact that
a couple in Arizona decided to drink
parasite treatment for fish in order to
prevent the corona virus now the man
unfortunately died the woman in last I
heard is in critical care in the
hospital so it's very sad but they drank
parasitic treatment for fish and that's
what happens now and this is very sad as
I said it's not really news worthy and
it certainly has nothing to do with
Trump but the media reported this story
breathlessly last night because they
thought they could pin it on Trump and
here's the NBC report on it and I'll
show you this you'll understand how
they're trying to connect it to Trump I
want you to also pay attention how long
does it take the reporter to mention
that they didn't take the medicinal form
of this drug they were looking for but
they they took it in the form of
something that you would buy at Petsmart
how long does it take him to actually
mention that here's the clip the
development this morning an Arizona man
has died after he took chloroquine
phosphate because he believed it would
protect him from the corona virus you
may recall the president has been
talking about chloroquine in a tablet
form which is a malaria drug which he
believes could in fact help people who
are struggling with the court with the
crew on a virus they talked to this
man's wife who is now also in
I see you about how and why he took this
particular chloroquine phosphate
did you see the president's press
conference where did you hear about and
then what and then what did you did you
seek out chloroquine
so this particular form of it that he
took was used to kill parasites and fish
apparently as you know the FDA is
looking at whether
chloroquine could be used it's a malaria
drug could be used to help people with
coronavirus but not in a raw form
certainly not in the form that you would
use to kill fish parasites okay Trump
mentioned chloroquine they were looking
for that and they took some and then
when we're well into the news report
we're about a minute in that's when the
reporter says oh yeah by the way it was
a fish treatment was parasite Tribute
fish that's that's what they took it
wasn't a medicine so this would be like
if I said that drinking an alcoholic
beverage at night can reduce stress and
then you went home and drank a gallon of
nail polish remover and died and
everybody blamed me or if I said that
petroleum jelly is a good way to treat
you know if you have dry skin use some
petroleum jelly and then you went home
and our you went to the gas station and
smeared gasoline all over your face and
went blind and everybody blamed me it
just it's completely ridiculous and
cynical and exploitative that reporter
NBC the rest of the media that was doing
this they're exploiting the suffering of
these people and not only that but
they're they're taking these people this
this woman who just lost her husband
exploiting her and they're traipsing her
out in front of the world to be laughed
at which is what happened how you got
all these people on social media
laughing at them mocking them which is
inevitable with something like this and
and of course it is an enormous ly
foolish thing to do obviously but at the
same time somebody died so it's a very
sad thing I can see this being a new
story locally in Arizona maybe the local
Arizona affiliate will pick it up but
it's this is not national news the media
doesn't care though we're going to take
these people use them as pawns use their
suffering as pawns put them out in front
of the world to be laughed at and mocked
all for the sake of landing a blow on
Trump it's despicable
evil let's go on to emails and if you
become a daily wire remember you can
always send an email to the mail back so
I would encourage you to do that this is
an email from Stan says hi Matt I need
to address the nearly hairless elephant
in the room what happened to your beard
man you do the show on Monday with your
luscious beard almost completely gone
and don't even offer an explanation I
feel betrayed you are no longer a fellow
beardsman I do not know you
first of all Stan can I say I don't mean
to deflect but please do not ever
describe something on my body as
luscious it is simply not a word that
men should ever be using in reference to
each other but you're right of course
it is a luscious beard or it was
honestly I have no defense
I could only throw myself at the feet of
the beardsman counsel and beg for your
indulgence which is a thing by the way
as we don't know for your indulgence and
forgiveness all I can say is it was a
moment of quarantine induced mania or or
qim as it's called now in the psychic in
the psychiatric community I here's
here's all it happened I was I was
getting ready for the day I'm going a
little stir-crazy like everybody else is
getting ready for the day I'm in the
bathroom on a whim I grabbed the
Clippers and I shared my beard right off
I don't know why I really don't know why
I did it and then when I realized what I
had done no I
I dropped the Clippers a very dramatic
moment I dropped them I stared in the
mirror in shock I said oh god what have
I done I broke down and the phone the
floor weeping hysterically that my wife
came in she found me sobbing in the
fetal position on the floor and said
again it was just a bad time all around
it was really a bad time but I all I can
do is try to grow the beard back and I'm
also afraid that because we hear about
how beards spread disease during the
coronavirus oh I'm afraid that I have
contributed to the stigma of beards by
trimming mine during a pandemic I didn't
intend to do that I want to make that
very clear this is from Owen says hello
Matt long time listener this is our why
you're wrong email for the day this is
from Owen says hello Matt long time
listener a fan of your show I disagree
with your takes often but very much
enjoy listening to the logical
presentations
the arguments you make which forces me
and your other listeners to think
critically about our own arguments with
regards to our core beliefs which I
think too many people engage in too few
too few people engaging we should say my
question is in regards to what you said
on your show today you said that the
mitigation of the loss of a single life
is not worth the economic hardship that
would befall everybody given the
alternative that the government is
currently implementing on a micro
economic level how exactly is this
different that an individual who has
fallen on economically hard times
deciding to get an abortion simply for
the sake of the economic gain received
by doing so you said that there's
obviously a line a number of human lives
lost in which the argument would tip to
the to one side or the other but this
kind of cold utilitarianism seems
generally out of line with the moral
arguments that you yourself often make
regarding the inherent value and
preciousness of human life to put simply
are there any conditions in in terms of
an individual's economics under which
you would condone an abortion and if not
how is this any different than a larger
scale version albeit much larger of a
similar scenario playing out right now
in which you say that a certain number
of deaths are acceptable if it keeps
millions out of poverty the death of a
single individual is unacceptable for
the economic gain of the individual but
the death of thousands is acceptable for
the economic gain of millions is it just
the scale alone what if a thousand
abortions happen for the economic gain
of millions I don't know exactly what
how that would be the case but you see
my point obviously well so there are a
few things there good question good
points I think there are a few things to
consider and so we've got kind of a ends
justify the means
versus principle of double effect thing
here which we've talked about on the
show before because it seems to come up
a lot these ethical disputes and
quandary there's a big difference okay a
number of differences but let's focus on
one an abortion is the direct
intentional killing of a human life you
are directly taking human life you're
killing somebody what I would say is
that it is never okay it is never
ethical it is never moral to directly
kill an innocent human life never okay
there could never be any benefit that
would make it okay because it's
inherently wrong and I don't care if
killing one person will make everybody
else in the world millionaires doesn't
matter I couldn't even begin to make it
okay but what we're talking about here
with with the plan that I'm proposing
others are proposing if we start to
hoping the economy up we take steps we
take precautions to try to stave off a
mass outbreak that kills a lot of people
well we're not talking about directly
killing people I'm not saying that we
see the analogy would be if I was
suggesting that we go and just kill
everybody who has the disease in order
to stop others from getting it that
obvious now even if I could prove to you
and I could show that doing that would
be economically beneficial and would be
beneficial to public health which which
maybe it would be that obviously would
be gravely immoral and psychotic but
we're not talking about that we're
talking about doing our best in a
difficult situation to preserve you know
as many lives as we can while also
staving off suffering and and the
collapse of human civilization of
American civilization as much as we can
so that's those are the two things we're
trying to balance it's it's we're not
directly killing anybody so directly
killing someone an innocent person
because you think it's gonna benefit you
or benefit others
that is an ends justify the means
approach which is wrong what we're
talking about here is more a double
effect situation where we're I'm saying
we do a good thing the good thing is
allowing people to work and feed their
families good thing which may possibly
have a negative even a potentially very
negative side effect but we're not doing
the negative thing in order for the good
thing to happen we're doing the good
thing knowing that a negative thing may
come up and may come from it which is
the same calculation now those who are
saying let's state keep it locked down
they're making the exact same
calculation they're saying
okay we're gonna keep it locked down to
try to save lives even though it's gonna
crash our economy and many millions of
people will suffer and die because of
that so either way you're stuck with
that kind of calculation and I don't
think that whichever way you go either
way is necessarily inherently immoral I
just think that it's certainly a lot
more prudent and will probably be more
effective and will preserve more lives
and stave off more suffering if we go
the route of opening things up again and
taking the precautions that I that I
just mentioned
so hopefully that explains it and that's
why we keep wanting to emphasize that
there I don't think we have to choose
between opening the economy and trying
to prevent an outbreak I don't think I
think that's a false choice I think we
can do both I think there is a way to do
both and if we begin from the premise of
ruling out any strategy that would
essentially in would would almost
certainly result in the destruction of
our economy if we rule that out to begin
with which I think we should because the
cost there is just far too great then we
could start thinking about other ways
and I think there are other ways I've
suggested one there are other ways of
doing it too there are even other rather
strict and and arguably draconian laws
that could be put in place while still
allowing people to work and feed their
families I mentioned the thing about the
mask there are some people suggesting
there should be a nationwide masks law
that everybody has to learn masks on
when they go outside now I'm not
suggesting that I don't know how that
would be enforced I also don't think we
have enough masks to even do that I
would worry about depriving the
hospitals of masks where they really
need it but I would take that would
certainly take that over causing a great
depression that would obviously to me be
exponentially better so even that if
you're inclined to support the more
draconian governmental measures why do
you start thinking in that direction
alright but thanks for the email thanks
everybody for watching listening we'll
leave it there Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer austin stevens editor
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 House and Senate Democrats torpedo a
bipartisan coronavirus relief bill
raising an important question if elected
Democrats are in taking the pandemic
seriously why should we we will examine
the political shenanigans and the light
at the end of the economic tunnel then
the mainstream media spread a story of a
man dying from the drug touted by
President Trump as a possible cure for
coronavirus the only problem with their
story is it's completely false we'll
take a look at what really happened
check it out on the Michael Noel's show